[Music]
my name is adina sterling i'm
an associate professor in organizational
behavior i
teach a course for mba students called
equity by design
on how to build diverse and inclusive
organizations
i also teach in the phd program and
in the msx program
i was a diaper engineer what that meant
was that i i did product design work
and we would collect product after use
because we had to look at the integrity
and the design of the product
so you can think about what that might
mean
that was a lot of fun but a part of me
had always
had this dream of going to graduate
school
and there was this great conference i
went to
that focuses on increasing the diversity
of business school faculty that was the
beginning of me deciding
that i was interested in getting a phd
from a business school
when i was at p g i'd been there maybe
two and a half years
and my my section had the main manager
over a group of engineers
came to me and said adina you have a
social network that
it takes people in the company two
decades to build
and i thought that's interesting but it
in graduate school i began to think
about how it was
that people end up with the social
networks that they do
and one of the aspects of my time at png
that came to mind
was a internship i had my associate
director
graduated from the same high school in
iowa that i had
we immediately connected and the
relationship i had with her and the
wonderful
mentoring i got from her opened up a ton
of doors for me
at png and so i began to be really
interested in
what gives people opportunities social
opportunities
and the broader social structures that
are underlying the kinds of connections
that people have
and all of these kinds of commonalities
that i think can sometimes
lead to hidden advantages and
disadvantages
during the course of a career
i think rigor is hopefully one
and creativity it's really typical in
graduate school to think about
what topic is sort of most hot and kind
of
you know what's getting published and
for better or worse i like to go into
fields of inquiry and ask questions that
nobody else is asking in my work i think
a lot about
figuring out what those undercover
mechanisms are
that lead to inequity and try to get
that
through a variety of methods
one of the things i've had the pleasure
of doing is
putting together webinars and some
seminars for companies on how to
improve the diversity of their hiring
pools and
those companies after i've i've provided
them content will frequently come back
and tell me
that they have implemented some of the
ideas that i've talked about
and that they are seeing a difference
and it's it is
very gratifying when that when that
happens
so something that i will frequently say
to my mba students
is that the real opposite of
inclusion isn't exclusion it's
conformity
that a lot of the benefits of diversity
get weeded out because we're looking for
people that think a certain way
that you know act a particular way and
if i could do one intervention it would
be to really
help people think about the beauty of
diversity
and in a broader and more nuanced way
i do get really excited that when i
study
i get to talk about in the classroom
with amazing
mba students and amazing phd students
and they're just so
determined to change the world and that
and that's inspiring
and then those amazing mba students
graduate and then they'll come back and
talk to me about or send me an email
about
what sorts of things they're doing in
the workplace
i get so excited i just have an amazing
job because i get to
to think about how to make the world a
better place and then immediately
interact with with students who are
striving to do the same thing and then
go out into the world
and do just that